after nearly a week of protest and
disruption this was the end of the
standoff on ambassador bridge
since saturday canadian police in
windsor ontario have been gradually
enforcing a court order made on friday
to end the demonstration
by sunday only a few stragglers remained
most had left or been arrested and their
vehicles towed away
the bridge is one of canada's most
important routes to the u.s with 25
percent of trade between the two
countries using it
but for six days it was shut as a
protest started by truckers angry at
mandatory covered vaccine certifications
blocked it off and the mandates and the
passports and let us live our lives
we're sick and tired of it
canada's freedom convoy as they called
it looks to be over now but the idea has
spread this is paris france 150 or so
cars setting off first to lille and then
on to brussels
we will tell europe to join us so we can
change things because the people need to
make their voice heard to know that we
are here today we have the impression
that we are looked down on things are
forced on us and we are forced to get
vaccinated in order to keep our jobs we
don't want that we don't want the
suppression we want to be free
brussels was quiet on sunday but maybe
not for long because of covid
governments in western democracies have
placed restrictions on people's lives
not seen outside of wartime most
citizens have complied seeing them as
for the greater good
but a vocal minority of finding ways to
make their opposition heard rory
challen's al jazeera